we are told a large nationwide poll
recently showed an unemployment rate of
nine percent in the united states the
mayor of a local town wonders if this
national result holds true for her town
so she plans on taking a sample of her
residence to see if the unemployment
rate is significantly different than
nine percent in her town
let p represent the unemployment rate in
her town
here are the hypotheses she'll use so
her null hypothesis is that hey the
unemployment rate in her town is the
same as for the country and her
alternative hypothesis is that it is not
the same
under which of the following conditions
would the mayor commit a type 1 error so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own
now let's work through this together so
let's just remind ourselves what a type
error even is
this is a situation where we reject the
null hypothesis even though it is true
reject null hypothesis even
though
even though our null hypothesis is true
and in general if you're committing
either a type 1 or a type 2 error you're
doing the wrong thing you're doing
something that somehow contradicts
reality even though you didn't intend to
and so in this case that would be reject
rejecting the hypothesis that the
unemployment rate is nine percent in
this town even though it actually is
nine percent in this town so let's see
which of these choices match up to that
she concludes the town's unemployment
rate is not nine percent when it
actually is
yeah this
in this situation in order to conclude
that the unemployment rate is not nine
percent she would have to reject the
null hypothesis even though the null
hypothesis is actually true even though
the unemployment rate actually is 9
so i'm liking the this choice but let's
read the other ones just to make sure
she concludes the town's unemployment
rate is not nine percent when it
actually is not
well this wouldn't be an error if the
null hypothesis isn't true it's not a
problem to reject it so this one
wouldn't be an error she concludes the
town's unemployment rate is nine percent
when it actually is
well once again this would not be an
error this would be failing to reject
the null hypothesis when the null
hypothesis is actually true not an error
choice d she concludes the town's
unemployment rate is nine percent
when it actually is not so this is a
situation where she
fails to reject the null hypothesis even
though the null hypoth even though the
null hypothesis is not true so this one
right over here this one would actually
be this is an error this is an error but
this is a type
error so one way to think about it first
you say okay am i making an error am i
rejecting something that's true or am i
failing to reject something that's false
and the rejecting something that is true
that's type one and failing to reject
something that is false that is type two
and so with that in mind let's do
another example
a large university is curious if they
should build another cafeteria they plan
to survey a sample of their students to
see if there is strong evidence that the
proportion interested in a meal plan is
higher than 40 percent in which case
they will consider building a new
cafeteria
let p represent the proportion of
students interested in a meal plan here
are the hypotheses they'll use
so the null hypothesis is that 40 or
fewer of the students are interested in
a meal plan well the alternative
hypothesis is that more than 40 are
interested
what would be the consequence of a type
2 error in this context so once again
pause this video and try to answer this
for yourself
okay now let's do it together let's just
remind ourselves what a type two area is
we just talked about it so failing
failing to
reject
in this case our null hypothesis
even
even though
it
is
false
so this would be a scenario where this
is false
which would mean that more than 40
actually do want a meal plan but you
fail to reject this so what would happen
is is that you wouldn't build another
cafeteria because you'd say hey you know
there's not that many people who are
interested in the meal plan but you
wouldn't but actually there are a lot of
people who are interested in the meal
plan so you probably won't have enough
cafeteria space and so this says they
don't consider building a new cafeteria
when they should yeah this is exactly
right
they don't consider building a new
cafeteria when they shouldn't well this
would just be a correct conclusion
they consider building a new cafeteria
when they shouldn't
and so this is a scenario where they do
reject the null hypothesis even though
the null hypothesis is true so this
right over here would be a type 1 error
type
error
because if they're considering building
a new cafeteria that means they rejected
the null hypothesis even when they
shouldn't that means that the null
hypothesis was true so type 1. they
consider building a new cafeteria when
they should well once again this
wouldn't be an error at all this would
be a correct conclusion this one and
this one are correct conclusions this is
the concept a and c are the consequences
of a type 2 and a type 1 error
respectively